bon il y a des propositions en tout cas
en matière de tourisme avec nous livre
la lumière pdg de tourisme montréal
bonsoir monsieur la lumière ont su
fillon alors le comité aujourd'hui à
proposer d'investir pour diffuser des
festivals en ligne favoriser aussi pour
2020 la multiplication de plus petits
événements au chapitre touristique c'est
ce qu'on propose qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
c'est sûr que montréal était frappé
autant au niveau touristique autant au
niveau des festivals et des événements
également et du sport donc non seulement
c'est un problème au niveau du tourisme
mais aussi la réputation de montréal en
termes de centres de l'épidémie au
canada donc on a notre réputation
un roboratif qu'on est une ville de
festivals et d'événements
c'est sûr que c'est un élément important
et on doit protéger nos festivals et
événements dans les prochaines les
prochains mois mais est-ce que les
propositions aujourd'hui de ce plan de
relance viennent assurer une relance du
secteur touristique pour vous je non
c'est sûr qu'on a besoin de beaucoup
plus que ça au niveau autant au niveau
fédéral que provincial avec un plan de
relance de montréal au niveau fédéral
c'est bien évident qu'on doit repartir
la machine au niveau des frontières
c'est à dire simplifier et clarifier des
règles du jeu pour encourager
l'exploration du canada la même chose
aussi pour au niveau des frontières
internationales quand les autres pays
pourront travailler avec nous de façon
sécuritaire on sait que les airs ou par
les lignes aériennes ont déjà des
protocoles 50 ans ça sera de fin aux
gens de deux ponts aériens ou six entre
le canada et les pays internationaux qui
sera en mesure de venir chez nous et
finalement de cibler de façon mesurée la
quarantaine parce qu'on peut pas
demander aux gens d'affaires et aux gens
de voyageurs de loisirs de venir dans
d'autres pays
et on soude est en quarantaine c'est sûr
que ça va pas alain faudra essayer de
faciliter cet aspect là avec les pays
encore avec lesquels on peut travailler
ce qu'on appelle un genre de bobos comme
on a fait en
dans l'union européenne en ce moment
c'est à dire au niveau de québec mais
c'est sûr ces ses dirigeants de ponts
aériens se dire qu'on accepte entre
l'australie et la nouvelle zélande de
deux voyages entre ces deux pays là de
façon sécuritaire donc on recommence la
machine avec un pays avec deux pays avec
30 pays
donc ça c'est trop de rire les irlande
publié aujourd'hui c'est sûr qu'on a
besoin d'attendre un petit peu là mais
on pourrait très bien voir la france à
partir du mois d'août où on prêtait de
voir les états unis à partir du mois de
septembre prévoir l'allemagne à partir
du mode ou un des pays qui sont déjà un
petit peu plus avancé ouais on voyait de
10 millions de visiteurs en moins c'est
10 millions de visiteurs en moins prévus
cette année à montréal
oui c'est incroyable c'est vraiment
catastrophique pour nous parce
qu'habituellement on reçoit 11.2
millions on a une super rallye n'est pas
en c'est une super bonne et avec un
moment un momentum de 10% voyages
internationaux en croissance cette année
alors pour nous c'est 90% des visiteurs
sont réussis par partir dans les
prochains mois de déconfinement la phase
de confinement du québec pour montréal
ça c'est extrêmement important qu'on
puisse voir des visiteurs en août et en
septembre
autant au niveau du québec que d'une
lettre au canada c'est quand même énorme
les chiffres que vous donnez est-ce que
vous avez l'impression d'avoir été un
peu que le secteur touristique a été
oubliée par les gouvernements je pense
que oui monsieur fillion vous de vous
savez au niveau économique le tour et
c'est toujours sous-estimé jusqu'à tant
qu'à montréal à l'été le magasinage ça
représente 50 % des factures des
commerçants alors on voit s'en
apercevoir de roulement et très bientôt
lyon un risque on a un risque de
fermeture d'hôtel de fermeture des
attraits ainsi important fermeture des
restos peut-être jusqu'à 50 % montréal
son report pour la deuxième phase de
confinement très bientôt
montréal ville de festivals qui attire
beaucoup beaucoup de gens est ce qu'il
ya des festivals qui pourrait finalement
ne pas revenir selon vous
je pense que les mesures adoptées par et
tourisme montréal le grenat du québec et
du canada pour protéger le financement
des festivals à date devrait faire en
sorte on va les retrouver tous
cette année on a encore la possibilité
d'avoir ces deux montréal et on a aussi
peut-être le grand prix lucky qui est
toujours le voulait willy stand-by
effectivement il devait avoir lieu là là
à peu près le début du mois deux joueurs
on a devrait reporter reporter quoi
l'automne est ce que vous avez espoir
que ça puisse se tenir un automne oui a
toujours espoir on regarde pour la
mi-septembre vous avez vu que le
calendrier était publié aujourd'hui
jusqu'à peu près au 1er septembre donc
il ya toujours trois options pour nous
est toujours l'annulation de la bande de
la f1 le départ les mots des mesures
sanitaires 1-1 1-1 repart donc en
septembre
ou sinon un grand prix à huis clos ou à
distanciation physique donnerait
peut-être intrants % de visiteurs ça
reste quand même événement numéro un au
canada
autre autre aspect particulier de
montréal c'est le tourisme d'affaires le
tourisme d'affaires est important pour
montréal quelques alice est important du
tourisme d'affaires
un moyen des premières villes en
amérique au niveau de réception de
congrès internationaux
le gamin 80 organisations
internationales à montréal donc ça
représente énormément de deux nuitées
pour nous pour le nom hôteliers et cette
année à date on a déjà perdu 200 mille
nuitées ou l'équivalent de 110 millions
$ en retombées économiques
si on est capable de protéger notre
saison de septembre et octobre
alors qu'on a encore 1 200 événements
dont les grands congrès avec un
protocole sanitaire dans les hôtels puis
palais mais on pourrait sauver une
partie de notre saison touristique à
partir du rapport d'expert qui a été
déposée aujourd'hui la mairesse plante
va présenter dans les prochains jours
son plan de relance pour montréal qu'est
ce que vous attendez de ce côté là c'est
sûr que on a on a beaucoup de travail à
faire la réputation de montréal a été
entachée même si toute une ville où il
fait bon vivre vivre ensemble d'une
excellente réputation en termes
d'ouverture
donc on a beaucoup de travail parce
qu'on sait que énormément de restaurants
à montréal et ça c'est difficile comme
deuxième ville après new york en termes
de nombre de restaurants et on pense
qu'on va perdre quand même 30 à 50 %
dont on doit rebâtir le produit
touristique montréalais
cette bible cette fibre là c'est à dire
autant la personnalité de montréal tout
l'aspect du le festival isation de la
culture et finalement l'aspect
gastronomique qui font en sorte que les
gens viennent chez nous nous visiter en
plus il faut ré
il faut rétablir les ponts avec les
régions parfait on s'arrête là dessus
merci beaucoup bonne chance monsieur la
lumière merci pour cet entretien ce soir